now it's no secret that a considerable
amount of posts on reddit for this game
consists of the devotion being nerfed
and a lot of people out of people in the
community to agree that this devotion
should be nerfed because of how it acts
of how it acts in the way that the gun
is but how about we take a step back
from talking about that we should nerf
the gun how about we go over why it's
considered overpowered and ways we can
go around to defeat it because if we
keep telling the developers to nerf more
guns like we talk people talk about nerf
in town people talk about nerfing the
devotion the g2 someone said the hemlock
we're going to over nerf this game and
then it's going to ruin it like destiny
didn't and that's not what we want
because the developers are going to
listen to us they're a great team of
people but if they keep listening to us
sometimes it could get worse so let's go
over why this devotion is considered
overpowered and what it has well for one
it has the speed the rate of fire has
the speed of an SMG almost competing
against the r97 if it reaches full speed
it hits harder than most assault rifles
it can it can the hemlock in three
bursts or just one burst with three
bullets almost kill almost every pilot
from a decent distance the devotion can
do just about the same if you were if
you were to tap it and put in the right
hands this thing has almost the accuracy
of a sniper if people have good enough
accuracy usually people will start
combining it with the a ball camping in
corners with the devotion it's a really
good Titan killer loadout popping an
amped wall with a devotion can kill and
can kill a Titan almost get them doomed
with an entire clip depending on who
you're killing if it's like a legion or
a scorch it will get them down to about
half up half a bar left or if it's like
a tone or an aronan they're practically
doomed so this thing is definitely
useful for ant walls but a lot of people
have been using it in camping with it
now like I said I could I could start
complaining about nerfing it but I
wouldn't be really entertaining because
as I said everyone talks about nerfing
it so I came up with ideas that we can
use to defeat this gun now the most of
the things that I've come up with are
pretty basic if you have a run-and-gun
style if you roll the if you roll with
the alternator the Volt and you're
zipping around with a grapple hook pulse
blade if you're running around the map
at super high speeds with stem but if
you have one of those running gun
loadouts you're all what you're nine
times out of ten gonna win the gunfight
if you're using a devotion you're not
going to run around because the hipfire
with the gun is god-awful the
alternator's hipfire is practically
perfect so that's why people use it for
run and gunning same with the vault the
devotion on the other hand is complete
garbage so people are going to sit still
and they're going to take their time and
aim like they're playing call of duty
and that gives you a perfect opportunity
to sneak around and kill their ass now
speaking of sneaking around the next
thing you can do is flanked them the gun
has a super distinct sound that it has
when you fire and you can tell go into a
game shoot the devotion and just listen
for that it's not that hard to
distinguish that gun from every other
gun in the game and like I said before
since they're carrying an LMG they're
not mobile as it is yeah they can wall
run and do all that stuff but they're
not going to be wall running and
shooting you as if somebody were having
an alternator or a volt and another idea
that you can use is if you're one of the
sniper players using a craver a
double-take stuff like that you can be
from far distances and they won't even
see you if you're playing on exoplanet
and you're camping all the way up at the
top of the one tower somehow you got up
there I don't snipe so I don't know how
you got up there but if you got up there
somehow props to you no one will see you
you sit there with a g2 it's basically
another [ __ ] sniper you're fine like
i said i made this video because people
keep complaining about nerfing things
and we should assess the situation and
figure out what's wrong with it
and how to defeat it now yes I do
believe that they could nerf this gun it
could it would help a lot but there are
other things that they should definitely
focus on more than nerfing this gun
other than that quick video nothing too
big subscribe if you guys are new though
I just hit 50 subscribers so I'm super
[ __ ] happy about that damn I was so
happy when I woke up to that today thank
you guys for 50 subs holy [ __ ] so anyway
guys subscribe if you're new to this
channel always going to be more
titanfall stuff and around mid-january
I'm going to be doing the for honor beta
when that comes out I did sign up so
hopefully we'll get a code and
especially going to be playing if the
game is good definitely going to be
recording some gameplay for all of you
and like the video if you did enjoy this
tell me other ideas that you want to
come if you want me to come up with you
know talking about discussion videos and
such a rhythm of making these and come
in your opinion if any of these were
good ideas or leave comments in the
description for leave comments for
people that are for other ideas for
people to come up with so that other
people can find more ways to defeat him
or to defeat the devotion any of you
guys peace out